[Musik]
hallo giulia guten morgen
hallo sandra
die geht's
du siehst müde aus
gestern abend ist es spät geworden
ich war zu einer party eingeladen
ich verstehe du hast ein bisschen zu
viel gefeiert
ja ich habe die zeit vergessen
also habe ich heute morgen verschlafen
und als ich ins büro gekommen bin
habe ich viele dokumente zum lesen
gefunden
habe ich
viele dokumente zum lesen gefunden
und e mails zu beantworten
erst jetzt hatte ich zeit in die
cafeteria zu kommen und einen kaffee zu
trinken
erst jetzt hatte ich zeit in die
cafeteria zu kommen und einen kaffee zu
trinken
außerdem habe ich in 40 minuten eine
besprechung mit dem chef
und ich habe starke kopfschmerzen
oh nein brauchst du eine
kopfschmerztablette
brauchst du eine kopfschmerztablette
danke aber ich möchte nur einen kaffee
trinken
trinken ja aber es ist besser auch etwas
zu essen
ja aber es ist besser auch etwas zu
essen
warte hier warte hier
hallo guten tag
ich hätte gern einen cappuccino einen
kaffee und zwei kuchenstücke
ich hätte gern einen cappuccino
ein café
und zwei kuchenstücke
danke sandra aber ein café ist genug
nein nein du musst etwas essen und dann
nimmst du eine tablette gegen deine
kopfschmerzen
nein nein du musst etwas essen und dann
nimmst du eine tablette gegen deine
kopfschmerzen
ich habe immer welche dabei
du bist net danke
hier ist ihre bestellung macht sieben
euro 60
hier ist ihre bestellung
macht sieben euro 60
dankeschön schönen tag
com setzen wir uns
wir haben noch zeit von einer
besprechung
sag mal wie war die party
sehr schön
es war die geburtstagsparty einer
freundin
sie hat in einer disco gefeiert
sie hat in einer disco gefeiert es gab
gute musik viele leute und vielleicht
habe ich ein bisschen zu viel getrunken
es gab gute musik viele leute und
vielleicht habe ich ein bisschen zu viel
getrunken aber du solltest nicht zu viel
trinken
wenn du am nächsten tag arbeiten muss
aber du solltest nicht so viel trinken
ja das ist wahr
aber die partie war es so lustig
aber die partie war so lustig
was hat deine freundin als geschenk
bekommen
ihre eltern haben ihr ein neues handy
geschenkt
ein paar freunde haben ihr eines smart
watch geschenkt
ich habe
ihr zwei schöne kleider gekauft die ihr
sehr gefallen
ich habe ihr zwei schöne kleider gekauft
die ihr sehr gefallen
schließlich hat sie eine neue tasche
bekommen
so viele schöne geschenke
weißt du dieser kuchen ist wirklich gut
hast du gesehen
hier geht es schon besser
du hast immer so viel energie du hast
immer so viel energie
wie machst du das
es ist weil ich einen gesunden
lebensstil habe
ich ernähre mich gesund
ich trinke keinen alkohol oder
süssgetränke
ich rauche nicht
außerdem trainiere ich oft
am morgen bevor ich ins büro fahre gehe
ich
ich joggen
wow das würde ich nicht schaffen
immer müde
am morgen bin ich immer müde
ich schalte den wecker immer ein paar
mal aus bevor ich aufstehe
wecker immer ein paar mal aus bevor ich
aufstehe
es ist schon 10 uhr 30
in 15 minuten habe ich die besprechung
ich hoffe du fühlst dich besser
ja ich fühle mich besser danke
ich drücke dir die daumen für die
besprechung
danke
wollen wir später zusammen mittagspause
machen
klar wir sehen uns später
tschüss
[Musik]
was machst du um gesund zu bleiben
ernst du dich gesund
schreibe es in die kommentare
und denk dir das video gefallen hat
günter lasst uns einbringt
[Musik]
möchtest du noch weitere videos sehen
dann abonniere unseren kanal jeden
sonntag ein neues video
möchtest du noch weitere videos sehen
dann abonniere unseren kanal jeden
sonntag ein neues video